I do my job my job's about their block
shots cause having a defensible to the
floor lay it all out to the line from IT
make plays for this season we have a
great team and I think we really make a
serious playoff run this year you have
to have your own mindset your own
philosophies go back to your training
remember what got you here this is a
matter who we play
[Music]
life in the NBA come from chat can't let
it rattle you if you let your opponent
determine the way you view a game or
like your outlook on the game that's the
issue my future is on tap
taking working myself and better myself
day in and day out I watch a lot of film
is its able to show you every little
aspect of one individual play I think
that's something that's gonna really
allow him to see a better a better each
and every year I came to the league at
19 years old this is my fifth year now
and I haven't played that first round
ice yes I say so hi
don't anchor for one of the best
defensive teams in the league I want to
just keep it elevated assume new heights
bigger detail